Vì vụ anh em bị bài thành chiến cho biết, chuyến thăm cấp nhả nước của tổng thống Mỹ đồn tròm đã thu hút một tròn năm 2018.
Tất khoảng 2,5 lệ tư phải tả Mỹ bài tỉ đồn Mỹ đầu tư vào nức này.
Bà gồm cả các càng kết mới và càng kết đã được công bủ trực lỏ.
Có số trên được công bố một ngày sau khi tổng thống trăm, thăm ra các nghi thức khoảng ra và trước khi bước vào chuyện trình là việc với thu tưởng kia sdamer.
Này của nó có đầu tư thương mại lời nhất từ trước từ này vào anh, gặn liền với một chuyện thăm các nhả nước.
Trong số có khoảng đầu tư lượng có càng kết dài hạ, chỉ giám một chăm bà mề sảo tí đồn Mỹ của tập đoàn bộ phần tuy nhiên Blackstone,
cùng khoảng đầu tư năm 2018 tí đồn Mỹ từ prologist, dành cho linh buộc hợp đổi sống và sản xuất tiến tiến.
Chỉ phủ anh em mạnh, các càng kết đầu tư trên sẽ tạo ra khoảng 1,5 lệ,
đông thời hẳn định việc hai lần tiếp đón tổng thống phủ trăm chỉ trong thời gian gặn sẽ đêm lại lựa íc kinh tế thức.
Nói ra đoàn đơn đơn cùng công bố một số dưới ánh đồng tư và Mỹ trong đoàn có khoảng đầu tư và míti đồ cho khoảng đầu tư
miền kiểu và phát triển của hẳn dơ phẩm ZsGuy.